il ya aussi un côté ce qui va rester de
cette période qui j'espère va se
terminer bientôt mais ça restera quoi
qu'il arrive je pense qu'à un moment
donné ça pour être des photos d'archivés
un peu
[Musique]
quand est arrivé le confinement moins
bon travail cet arrêté
donc j'ai voulu en fait donner un sens à
mon confinement c'est à dire la bido
d'un petit village où je connais pas
grand bon parce que je suis très souvent
déplacements et donc pas dans le
confinement je le suivis bon pourrait
sortir faire des photos dans le temps à
qui les a autorisées
les premiers jo était un peu compliquée
voire désespérante parce que j'avais
sonner aux portes et les gens avaient un
petit peu peur de moi en fait ça a
commencé surtout avec les personnes qui
étaient dans leur jardin
donc j'étais en train de jardiner donc
là le contact bt était plus facile
[Musique]
ma première question c'était leur
demander si comment ils allaient en fait
parce que parce que enfermés chez eux ça
permettait d' engager la conversation
et ce qui est important important pour
moi aussi c'était de d'avoir après parce
que je trouvais que ça permettait de
personnaliser la photo et en même temps
je voulais absolument mettre leur métier
ou leur fonction parce que je trouvais
ça donne et diversité
[Musique]
enfin ça m'a apporté beaucoup de choses
parce que j'ai pas forcément un
tempérament à les verts allaient sonner
chez les gens vous allez passer dans la
rue et les interpeller c'est pas trop
dans mon tempérament
mais du coup de d'avoir mis en place ce
projet ça va obliger à aller vers les
autres
j'étais obligé de prendre le dessus
prendre sur moi découvrir les gens
parler avec eux et ça s'en va après beau
[Musique]
oh